headlines went around the world about a
week ago regarding a newly discovered 30
ton black granite sarcophagus the
largest ever found in the ancient city
of Alexandria Egypt not only that but it
is sealed shut with thick mortar
indicating that it has never been opened
since its burial avoiding grave robbers
for thousands of years which is actually
a very rare find now everyone is
wondering who or what will they find
inside of it and in this video I'm going
to be discussing some really interesting
details about this newly discovered
stone box details that were somehow left
out of the hundreds of news articles
from around the world on this topic and
the implications of these details leave
us with some serious questions that
scientists archeologists and historians
all need to address but perhaps more
significant is that it was just
announced today July 18th that they will
be opening this stone box in just two
days from today quote Egypt's Ministry
of Antiquities has finally decided to
open a mysterious sarcophagus uncovered
in Alexandria within the next two days
according to the head of Ministry of
Antiquities project Sektor it went on to
say that they will use thick pipes to
raise the sarcophagus lid until they can
see what's inside of it once something
is found a specialized restoration team
will immediately take over transferring
the contents into an Alexandria Museum
storage to quickly start restoration
procedures quote if nothing is found
inside the sarcophagus and we do not
find any inscriptions on the coffins
body we will keep it in place until it
can be lifted later so first of all
everybody needs to demand that the
opening of this sarcophagus is done on
live TV or even better yet live
streaming on the internet they could
even do it right here on YouTube and for
free
make no mistake everyone from around the
world has a right to be part of this
exciting discovery involving our ancient
past but not only that with the numerous
examples of corruption and theft
involving Egyptian antiquities in the
past full transparency on this is a must
and I'll be discussing more details
about that later in this video first let
me share some really interesting aspects
about this sarcophagus and the things
that they did not tell you
about in the news articles including
where this black granite originates from
which you may find a bit fascinating
first of all it's more than 30 metric
tons and to clarify the difference
between a u.s. ton and a metric ton
because not everybody knows a metric ton
is 1,000 kilograms and a US ton is 2,000
pounds in other words this coffin is
estimated to be no less than 66,000
pounds in fact the lid itself is 15 tons
and although it is not the largest
sarcophagus ever found it is the largest
discovered within alexandria measuring
nearly 9 feet long five and a half feet
wide and a staggering six feet tall and
that equates to 2.7 meters long 1.5 by
1.8 meters in height
one thing that is significant besides
its size and weight is that it's made of
black granite stone and the closest
place where black granite can be found
in the region is either in aswan egypt
which is about 140 miles away or 223
kilometers or the mountainous region of
eastern Egypt known as sinai which is
366 miles or 589 kilometers away and
just look at the map the further
distance to Sinai is not as the crow
flies but with the distance of the windy
roads that go up and down the Sinai
Mountains which of course begs the
question of how they could have and why
would they transport 66 thousand pounds
of stone up and down mountains obviously
the techniques suggested by
Egyptologists of sliding on wooden sleds
or rolling on tree logs isn't going to
work from this site so it's far more
likely that it would have come from
Aswan which is about like I said 140
miles away but they could utilize barges
on the Nile River as suggested by
archeologists but and although that's
feasible and I don't doubt this method I
would still like to see them actually
demonstrate them load and unload these
two 15 tonne pieces of this box onto a
boat and then unload it all while
dealing with the issues of balance and
counter weights I mean this is a
theorized method and not necessarily
what the ancient Egyptians actually used
but that aside what is more interesting
is where they found the sarcophagus
it was discovered by accident during
construction of a new building within
the city of Alexandria and keep in mind
that this city is densely populated this
only further validates that much of the
remnants of ancient Egypt is literally
under the streets and houses that exists
today this is something that I've
discussed before and take the example of
the massive statue discovered in March
of 2017 found in the middle of Cairo and
who knows what else is hidden and buried
in the immediate area around that
discovery another good example is the
2017 again discovery of a 130 thousand
year old set of Mastodon bones that have
evidence of human tooling and cut marks
which proves that ancient humans were in
America well over 100 thousand years
before ever thought possible by
academics and the implications of this
are enormous as it debunks what
scientists thought they knew about the
human migration process now I've
discussed that in other videos but the
reason why I'm bringing it up again is
because this discovery happened by
accident while doing construction on a
freeway in San Diego California and so
when you look at the vastness of the
modern city of Giza as an example we can
only imagine what lay hidden just meters
underneath that city but to re-emphasize
my point all of these recent discoveries
were found by accident so just imagine
what would find if we actually went
looking underneath the modern
infrastructure around ancient sites from
around the world so going back to the
black sarcophagus discovery and and that
reminds me and this isn't to sound like
a smartass or anything but they are of
course using heavy machinery to lift
this 30 ton stone box out of the 16 and
a half foot deep or five meters deep
hole where it was found and it's kind of
funny how Egyptologists never actually
demonstrate the theorized lifting
techniques they claimed the ancients
could have used and I'm not even
suggesting that I doubt these techniques
in fact I would bet money that they did
use pulleys but I feel obligated to
point out that most people that teach
this and write about it in textbooks
actually sit behind desks for a living
and never actually try out any of these
theories with their own hands I mean it
must be mentioned that these scientists
cannot even explain how the ancients
acts
he cut this granite box with such
precision I mean look at the angles on
this and obviously this thing has damage
and erosion so it will be fascinating to
see what the inside stonework looks like
once they open it up particularly how
level it is and the detailed precision
of the angles the very design of this
stone box particularly the lid is
incredibly similar although about
two-thirds smaller the size of that of
the 100-ton stone boxes at the Serra
pium of Saqqara located near Memphis
Egypt and even Zahi Hawass the disgraced
former minister of Antiquities of Egypt
and in my opinion a huge example of why
the newly discovered sarcophagus lid
should be opened on live TV is so
important but even this guy admitted on
live TV that they have no idea how the
dynastic Egyptians could have done these
and mind you that they are machined down
to 210 thousandths of an inch and the
corners are so precise that we can't do
this today without using routers and
diamond bit drills controlled by
computers so although these are much
larger in fact there are 27 of them by
the way and some measure as large as 14
feet high 10 feet wide and 15 feet long
and others are smaller and weigh 70 tons
but regardless these pictures never do
them justice for just how massive they
really are but it's interesting that the
shape of the lid is virtually the same
with the three cut angles when you
compare but the significance of the
comparison is ultimately related to the
fact that this is black granite and
bronze tooling that the dynastic
Egyptians had could not have cut through
this type of stone with anywhere near
this level of precision these methods
have indeed been tested and they failed
miserably they can only cut at a rate of
a couple millimeters an hour
literally and the saws wear out almost
immediately
there's no comparison of precision and
besides that no saws none of this size
have ever been found or even depicted in
hieroglyphs left by the ancient
Egyptians explain how a saw of this size
less than a two-foot blade and never
mind the fact that it's made of bronze
how is this thing going to cut through a
stone that is five and a half feet wide
the saw you're looking at now is the
best in largest found from ancient Egypt
and the depictions of this saw are
detailed by the Egyptians and can be
seen only being used to cut wood
actually it's ridiculous to suggest that
bronze would have been used to cut
through granite and it's ridiculous for
scientists to sketch up images of
massive bronze saws which there's no
evidence to suggest that they even
existed in the first place
and again when they made one and tested
it anyways it failed yet they still
teach these methods in school today you
see it's important to understand this
because it's called science and it's
actually being ignored by academics that
teach us about our ancient past if you
followed my other videos you've heard me
discuss numerous lines of evidence about
how ancient humans were far older and
advanced than we were ever taught in
school so in other words an advanced
civilization not necessarily as advanced
as we are today but advanced enough to
do things that we can't wrap our minds
around in but least involving this
ancient stonework something happened to
them about twelve to thirteen thousand
years ago during the Younger Dryas
cataclysmic event which they don't teach
that in school either and basically over
the last thirteen thousand years the
sands of time have eroded and erased
pretty much everything other than
megalithic stone work so when I see this
box and the 2000 year old narrative
within every single news article on the
topic it feels like a foolish rush to
judgment the only reason why they came
to this 2,000 year old theory was
because of this deteriorated alabaster
head found not far from this granite box
and this alabaster head is clearly
greco-roman so the timeframe would
coincide with Alexander the Great being
in Alexandria
so perhaps yeah maybe some noblemen
living there at that time is buried in
this box I mean really it would not
surprise me if some rich prick Roman
took this box for himself to be buried
in and that's who we find inside and of
course the Romans were there and set up
shop in Alexandria so of course it would
make sense to find some notable burials
in that area but that doesn't mean that
this box was created at that time what I
do know is if they don't open this
sealed sarcophagus on live video
conspiracy theories will likely be
formed by people who are aware of the
various cover-ups of the past involving
the ancient Egyptians and modern
antiquity
make no mistake and I'm not suggesting
that anyone involved in this discovery
would do anything to cover-up or mislead
anyone or anything but what that said
there is zero reason to not have full
transparency and public involvement in
this discovery I mean there's really no
acceptable reason to do this off camera
is there I mean because of Technology
the whole world can pretty much watch
this live so there's really no reason to
not do that unless there's something I'm
missing here right just think about how
exciting what an incredible event it
would be for people from around the
world to be able to tune in and watch
this on TV or like I said even on
YouTube because then they wouldn't even
have to plan around network schedules or
anything they could do it for free on
YouTube in fact they could make money
doing it and they could use that money
for future excavations and on top of all
that this is a huge PR opportunity for
Egyptian antiquities which are eager to
develop and grow Egyptians tourism
within ancient sites in the country in
general so with all this said it will be
very exciting to see over the next
couple days when they finally do open
this and what we find inside well that
is unless they don't video it and they
wait days and weeks into the future
before finally sharing with the public
what they found which is something
they've done numerous times in the past
anyways guys I'm gonna leave it at that
but leave a comment to let me know what
your thoughts are on all of this and hit
the like button and subscribe but I'm
Jimmy this is bright insight take care
everybody